dieses 2017 aufgenommene video wirbelt
die österreichische politik gerade
gehörig durcheinander und hat zum
rücktritt von vize kanzler und fdp chef
heinz christian strache geführt die
heimlich gemachten aufnahmen zeigen
strache im gespräch mit einer frau die
sich als nicht der eines russischen
oligarchen aus gibt strache erklärt ihr
wie sie der spd spenden zukommen lassen
kann ohne dass dies der rechnungshof
mitbekommt außerdem stellt er ihr im
gegenzug staatliche aufträge in aussicht
[Musik]
kurz nach der veröffentlichung erklärt
strache seinen rücktritt nicht ohne über
eine gezielte attacke zu klagen er habe
sich mit zunehmenden alkoholkonsum
polemisch geäußert dfb oder ihm bekannte
vereine hätten nie geld von der dame
angenommen
mit seinem rücktritt wolle er die
koalition mit der övp er retten
die bilder wurden spiegel und
süddeutsche zeitung nach eigenen angaben
zugespielt beide medienhäuser wollten
keine angaben zur herkunft machen